this attack by Turkish forces into Syria
is from the air and the ground now a
series of border towns are being
targeted smashed with sporadic artillery
they want to push the Kurdish led
Benicia away from the border creating a
buffer zone it's been planned for years
in Turkey
they've been dreading it here for just
as long
it is a military operation but it's
right into the heart of population
centers civilians on the front line have
no choice but to get out of town however
they can the truth is not everybody is
able to there are people still inside we
were hit in the morning by six or seven
shells and there are people who can't
leave because they don't have any
transport some people have cars others
don't
Syrian protesters turned out to show
their anger at what's going on here some
of their banners promised to turn the
northeastern part of the country into a
graveyard for the Turks and the Islamic
state fighters many of whom are
imprisoned here those prisoners are a
real problem Islamic state wives
celebrated the start of the Turkish
offensive in one camp outside another
prison they set fire to tires and called
for the release of the fighters taunting
the Kurdish guards to open fire it all
adds to the growing tension here some of
the world's leading aid agencies have
joined together issuing a statement
calling on all sides to show restraint
in this growing crisis they point out
that over 450,000 people live along the
border between Syria and Turkey and all
of them they say are in danger the
attacks are taking place around the
clock for their part the militia say
they're taking on the overwhelming might
of the Turkish army and holding them
back
but emergency teams are constantly being
deployed to pick up the injured and the
number of casualties are growing by the
day the vichy he's been hit by debris
from what appears to be a shell which
fell near him they said he was at home
or in his neighborhood he's been hit in
his head his neck his chest and stomach
we took scanners but you might need a
bigger surgery we need to stop the
bleeding now
hopefully he'll be fine it's difficult
to gauge what is going to happen here
the further escalation of the violence
can't be ruled out certainly both sides
are preparing for worse to come still
empty Sky News in Northeast Syria